I'm Tony Lepore.
They call me the Dancing Cop.
I'm from Providence, Rhode Island.
I've been directing traffic my way for 27 years.
I was kind of bored one day and plus I can dance and sing...
...and I always wanted to be an entertainer when I was younger.
And I just did a couple of spins and some hand movements and the people loved it.
I think it would be more of a distraction if I was in a different town...
...and they didn't know I was out there.
But most in Providence, they even know me by the sound of my whistle.
My joints take a beating, you're right.
But like only my chiropractor knows.
It's all rhythm or I'll go and interrupt it with one of these.
Or like I told you before, my hands are tied up and I can't, I'll give them one of these.